M.  Carson si les pauvres pouvaient faire plus
avec moins il n'y aurait pas de pauvres
[Musique] les
pauvres ne sont pas pauvres parce qu'ils
choisissent d'être monsieur vous avez indiqué qu'il y
aura des coupes substantielles dans le
budget de HUD pouvez-vous me donner ce
dollar  montant que je montre qu'il est d'
environ 6 milliards est que correct oui
madame est qu'environ 13 pour cent du
budget oui et avec ces coupes mr.
Carson provient de
bons de logement de logement public, de subventions globales de développement communautaire
et d'autres aides aux personnes à faible revenu
et ils proviennent de diverses
sources, y compris le montant du
logement public m.  Carson probablement dans le
quartier de si vous combinez tous les
programmes 2 à 3 milliards 2 à 3 milliards
combien de bons de logement mr.
Carson plutôt que de passer par un quiz sur
tous les chiffres, ce n'est pas un quiz mr.
Carson, j'ai le temps de vous poser
des questions sur des choses que vous devriez
connaître si vous n'en avez aucune
connaissance, vous pouvez simplement dire que
je l'accepterai comme réponse, mais c'est
quelque chose qui relève de votre bailliage
mon cher monsieur comment  beaucoup de bons de logement
encore une fois, vous savez que je peux vous donner
ce numéro, mais bon, si vous me
le donniez, je l'apprécierais beaucoup
parce que j'aimerais passer aux
subventions globales de développement communautaire, eh bien, voici mon
point, je suis d'accord avec vous que c'est
difficile de faire ces choses qui n'est pas cela
n'a pas grand chose à voir avec ma question
vous répondez à une question que je ne
pose pas pour être tout à fait franc avec vous alors
voudriez-vous gentiment me dire combien de HUD
va combien vous '  re va couper
du budget HUD en ce qui concerne les
bons de logement maintenant si vous ne savez pas
c'est correct de dire que vous ne savez pas mr.
Carson, je ne vous oblige pas à des choses que
vous ne savez pas, passons simplement à autre chose et
disons que je ne veux pas offrir de chiffre
car c'est subtil pourquoi le
secrétaire du HUD ne donnerait-il pas au chiffre le
montant que vous êtes  couper des
bons de logement mr.  Carson parce que le
secrétaire du HUD parce que tu fais
la coupe parce qu'on a déjà parlé
du montant total des coupes ben
le montant total ne m'aide pas quand il s'agit
des bons logement j'ai des
gens qui utilisent des bons logement et moi
besoin de pouvoir leur expliquer en tant que
Carson combien ils ont coupé de pauvres boîtes pour
eux combien mr.  Carson, écoutons votre
numéro de femme. Carson, pardonne-moi d'avoir
toussé en parlant, mais mr.  Carson,
vous êtes le témoin qui témoigne aujourd'hui et
si vous voulez un moment pour demander à quelqu'un
derrière vous, je serais ravi de vous accorder
ce moment, je ne veux pas ouvrir le
livre et regarder les chiffres, je vois comment
vous choisissez de ne pas dire combien  vous
coupez dans les bons de logement, d'accord,
combien vous coupez dans les subventions globales de la communauté,
m.  Carson, je veux parler
de m.  Carson, vous ne pouvez pas parler
de ce que vous voulez aujourd'hui, vous pouvez
parler de ce dont je veux que vous parliez,
vous devez répondre aux questions que j'ai
posées.  Carson ouais mais je réponds aussi à
la question de la façon dont vous pouvez y répondre comme
vous le souhaitez, mais si vous voulez montrer un
manque de connaissances, vous pouvez le faire,
c'est tout à fait bien mr.  Carson alors maintenant
combien de subventions globales de développement communautaire
mr.  secrétaire à nouveau, je ne suis pas
prêt à rester assis là et à partir, vous ne
savez pas combien de subventions globales de développement communautaire
je ne vais pas parcourir
la liste autant autant dans
autant je pense que je ne sais pas
je  'll déplacer sur m.  Carson, j'accepte
votre manque de connaissances